how much fun are you guys having here in
london celebrating with everybody oh my
gosh it's so much fun being in london
i've never come to london so it's it's a
thrill for me yeah it's so fun it's
really nice it's nice that we got to
hang out
i know yeah really fun yeah yeah now
when you guys started yellow jackets did
you know
it was going to you know
i didn't
i just yes we knew it was going to be
the best
no i didn't know
how could we i think we both have been
like doing this for so long that we
don't have expectations anymore yeah so
it just was a nice surprise yeah and i
think we both knew that the script was
really good and uh the actors were
really good that we were going to get to
work with and
so you you know you're doing something
good but the phenomenon that it became
no no
the truth is
the plane crashed a bunch of my friends
died
and then the rest of us starved and
scavenged
and prayed until they finally found us
there is a lot of emmys buzz surrounding
the show what would that recognition
mean to you
everything yeah i mean
i you you say that awards don't mean
anything but you know it's it's i reckon
that
[Applause]
speak for yourself i love you um no i i
think you know um
if the show gets nominated excellent if
melanie gets nominated that would be
you're getting them i've voted for you i
know you're not supposed to say
um
and like honestly the young cast of our
show is so good like that's my dream is
that one of them even if not this year
you know yeah
i think the material will be there for
you know for for seasons to come so yeah
with that being said when do you start
shooting the next season mid-august yeah
yeah i know excited going back to
vancouver what are you most excited to
keep
keep telling everyone with the story
i love working with melanie i think we
work really well together so it'll be
really fun to do more scenes together
hopefully have those intimate moments
where we get to break down our walls
those are my favorite moments of season
one
yeah me too i love working with you yeah
you guys are like we're not telling
anything that was a great one
that was good though
and the giant squid i'm really looking
forward to the giant squid i mean
[Laughter]
when we moved to the squid yes the
murdering the squid's gonna be a real
thrill
now it's super lock and key you can't
tell me anything but can you tell your
husband i mean can you tell jason
anything does he know any of the secrets
he doesn't want to know anything
he doesn't want to know anything at all
like while we were shooting sometimes
i'd be like oh so we were doing the same
with blah blah and he'd be like
stop stop stop he doesn't he's he wants
to just watch it
this time it's very fun because i watch
it one time and i watch it with him and
our nanny
and
so they're both like very surprised when
we're watching it's really fun
see him be a fan yeah exactly yeah he's
so into it oh my god
[Music]